量子コンピュータは、古典的なコンピュータだけでは解けない問題を、より速く解けると考えられている。だが
その仕組みは微妙だ。今日はQiskit in the classroomで、
最初期のアルゴリズムの一つを見ることで、量子コンピューティングの
力の源を探っていく。Qiskit in the classroomへようこそ。このシリーズでは、Qiskitを使って
量子コンピューティング関連の講義でよく扱われる基本的な概念を探求する。各動画には、
説明欄にリンクされたインタラクティブなモジュールが付いているので、ぜひ確認してほしい。量子コンピュータについてよく聞いたことがあるなら、
重ね合わせ、エンタングルメント、干渉といった量子現象を使って、
古典的なコンピュータにはできない方法で問題を解けると聞いたことがあるだろう。だが、これらの特性がどう役立つのか？1985年、David Deutschが
初めてその可能性を示した。彼は今日Deutschのアルゴリズムと呼ばれるものを考案し、
古典的なアルゴリズムよりも効率的に問題を解いた。今日は、Deutschのアルゴリズムと
その後の拡張であるDeutsch-Joszaアルゴリズムを見て、qubitの持つ量子的な特性が
量子コンピュータにどう活かせるかを考える。そして、Qiskitを使って実際の量子コンピュータでこれらのアルゴリズムを実行する。
既知の古典的なアルゴリズムより理論的な優位性を示す量子アルゴリズムは他にもある。そのすべてが
今日見るものと同じ原理で動くわけではない。だから今日学ぶことは、量子
コンピュータが一般的にどう動くかを説明するものではないが、量子力学の原理をどう組み合わせると
強力な量子コンピュータが作れるかを見え始めさせてくれる。Deutschのアルゴリズムに入る前に、まず量子コンピュータが
古典的なコンピュータとどう違うか、そしてそれがある種の問題を解く上で
どんな優位性をもたらすかを考えよう。一つの違いは、qubitと呼ばれる量子ビットが重ね合わせ状態になれることだ。
古典ビットのようにゼロ状態かイチ状態かに限られるのではなく、qubitは
ゼロとイチの両方の重ね合わせ状態になれる。この状態をこのように書く。
aとbは二乗の和が1になる複素数で、
qubitが増えるほど、このギャップは広がる。古典の2ビットは、これら
四つの可能な状態のうちの一つにしかなれない。0 0、1、1 0、または1
1だ。2つのqubitは、その四つの古典的に許される状態すべての重ね合わせになれる。これは
このように書く。一般的に、nビットの古典システムは2のn乗の可能な
ゼロとイチの組み合わせのうちの一つにしかなれない。nqubitの量子システムは、その2のn乗すべての
状態の重ね合わせになれる。このスケーリングは指数関数的だ。だから、たった10 qubitでも、
2の10乗、つまり1,024通りのゼロとイチの組み合わせの重ね合わせ状態に
なれる。qubitの状態空間の指数関数的なスケーリングは量子
並列性と呼ばれ、古典コンピュータに対する量子コンピュータの優位性の一因だ。だが、量子
コンピュータは単なる大規模並列プロセッサではない。量子コンピュータのqubitが指数関数的に多くの状態の
重ね合わせになれるからといって、それらの状態それぞれの情報にアクセスできるわけではない。
測定によってシステムがある状態に崩壊するため、
単純な問題でこれがどう現れるか見てみよう。
1ビットを入力できるマシンがあるとしよう。そのビットに何らかの関数を適用して、別の1ビットを出力する。このマシンは
アクセスできないブラックボックスの中にある。アクセスできるのは、
入力するビットxと、ボックスが出力するビットf
ofxだけだ。マシンが適用している関数fが何かを突き止めたい。
1ビットから別の1ビットへの関数は四つある。
だから関数を調べるには、ゼロを入力してゼロかイチが出るかを見ればいい。次に
イチを入力して同じことをする。この二つのステップそれぞれをクエリと呼ぶ。これは
古典アルゴリズムと量子アルゴリズムを比較する一つの方法で、いわゆるクエリモデルにより、
問題を解くためにブラックボックスに対してそれぞれのアルゴリズムが行うクエリ数を比較する。つまりこの場合、
古典的な方法は関数を知るためにボックスに2回クエリする必要があった。量子
コンピュータでブラックボックスにクエリすればもっとうまくできるか見てみよう。最初にゼロ、次にイチを入力する代わりに、
量子コンピュータはゼロとイチの重ね合わせにあるqubitを
ボックスに入力できる。つまり実質的に、1回のクエリで両方の入力をボックスに与えることになる。では
それは、1回のクエリだけで関数を知れるということか？
残念ながら、そうではない。量子コンピュータでテストするとこのアイデアがうまくいかない理由がわかる。
2つのqubitでcircuitを作る。ここでは上の線で表されるqubit zeroが、
マルーンのgateでUFとラベルされたブラックボックスに入力する状態Xだ。UF gateは
入力状態XとしてQubit zeroを取り、qubit oneに変換を施して
ゼロ状態をf ofxに変えるよう設計されている。だからqubit 1がゼロ状態から始まる限り、
出力はqubit 0がx、qubit 1がf ofxになる。だからx=0とx=1の両方に対して同時にf ofxを求めるために、
ブラックボックスに入力する前にqubit 0を0と1の重ね合わせにしてみる。それはゼロ状態を1/√2
(0 + 1)に変換するこの赤いHadamard gateで行う。だからblackbox gateの後、
qubit 1にf of 0とf of 1両方の重ね合わせが得られるはずだ。2つのqubitを測定するとき、
ブラックボックスの中にある関数は何か、という問いに答えることを期待している。Qiskitのprimitive samplerを使って
circuitを実行して結果を返してみよう。circuitを実行する回数はsamplesと呼ばれ、
ここのshotsというパラメータを変えることで設定できる。
circuitを実行する回数をここのshotsというパラメータで変えられる。
これはブラックボックスに対するクエリの数と等価だ。クエリ1回だけで
うまくいくか見てみよう。結果はこれだ。qubit 0はゼロと測定された。つまりそれが
入力値xで、qubit 1は1、つまり出力値f(x)だ。これで
f(0)=1がわかった。でもf(1)はどうだろう？ここに問題がある。一度
状態を測定すると重ね合わせは崩壊し、1回のクエリで関数の一部しか測定できなかった。
これだけではどの関数かを特定するために必要なことが全部わからない。そのためには
もう1回ボックスにクエリする必要がある。量子並列性の原理によってf(0)とf(1)を同時に
ブラックボックスに評価させることはできるが、両方の答えにアクセスすることはできない。
量子並列性だけでは十分じゃない。Deutscheのアルゴリズムは
ブラックボックス内の関数について学ぶために量子並列性を少し違う形で使う方法を示している。
関数が正確に何かを知ることはできないが、古典コンピュータではできないことを1回の
クエリで関数について新たなことを学べる。まず1ビットを別の1ビットに変換する4つの可能な
関数の表を見てみよう。f_sub_1とf_sub_4の2つの関数は、入力状態に関わらず常に
単一の値を返すのがわかる。この2つの関数を
定値関数と呼ぶ。f_sub_2とf_sub_3はxの状態によってゼロか1を返す。
この2つの関数を均衡関数と呼ぶ。Deutscheのアルゴリズムは
関数が定値か均衡かを、以前使ったcircuitにいくつかの巧妙な調整を加えることで判定する。
これがそのcircuitだ。まずqubit 0を状態1/
√2(|0⟩+|1⟩)に前と同じようにHadamardで準備し、qubit 1を状態1/√2(|0⟩-|1⟩)に
NOTゲートに続いてHadamardで準備する。
つまりここでの完全な状態はこうなる。これがqubit 0の状態で、
これがqubit 1の状態だ。qubit 1を単に
ゼロ状態のままにするのではなくこのように準備することで、アルゴリズムが量子並列性と干渉を組み合わせて
ブラックボックス関数について学ぶことができる。qubitがUFつまりブラックボックスgateに入力されると何が起きるか見てみよう。
関数が定値の場合、ブラックボックスはゼロの状態に関わらずqubit 1だけに何らかの操作を行う。
この場合、UFはqubit 0に触れず、その状態を全く気にしないので、
ここの2番目のHadamardは最初のHadamardがしたことを元に戻すだけだ。
そしてqubitはゼロ状態にあると測定される。均衡関数f_sub_2を例にして、UFがこの場合の状態にどう作用するか見てみよう。
xがゼロのとき、f(x)はゼロで、xが
1のとき、f(x)は1だ。UFgateについて話したことを覚えているか。qubit 0を
入力x状態として受け取り、f(x)をqubit 1に出力する。qubit 1が
ゼロ状態から始まると仮定して。この関数では、UFがqubit 1に何をするかは
qubit 0に依存する。0がゼロならqubit 1はf(
x)=0を得るためにゼロ状態のままになる。qubit 0が1なら、ブラックボックスはqubit 1にNOTゲートを適用して
状態1にする。つまりf(1)=1が得られる。これはまさにcontrolled-NOT、つまりCNOT gateがすることだ。
CNOT gateは2つのqubitを受け取る。control qubitとtarget qubitで、
control qubitが状態1にある場合にtarget qubitの状態を反転させる。しかしcontrolが
状態ゼロならtargetには何もしない。つまりF2のUFはQ0とQ1のCNOTだ。
CNOT gateはcontrol qubitがゼロ状態にあるため第1項には何もしない。でも第2項では、この
ゼロが1に、この1がゼロに反転する。マイナス符号を因数分解すると、qubit 1の状態は
変化していないことがわかる。でもこの項はマイナス符号を拾っている。つまりqubit 0の状態が
実際に変化したんだ。|0⟩+|1⟩から|0⟩-
1⟩になった。qubit 0に最終的なHadamardを適用すると、状態1に変換される。つまりブラックボックス内の関数が
f_sub_2なら、ゼロではなく1を測定する。もう一方の均衡関数f3のUF gateは
同じCNOT gateにqubit 1へのNOTが続くものだ。その最終的なNOTゲートはqubit 0に影響しない。だから関数が
均衡の場合、circuit終了時にqubit 0は状態1にあると測定される。これを全部理解できなかったとしても
大丈夫だ。自分で確かめてどう機能するか見てほしい。ここでの重要なポイントは
2つの均衡関数にCNOTを適用したときに何が起きたかだ。qubit 0はqubit 1の状態を変えるためにcontrol qubitとしてのみ使われた。
直感的にはqubit 0は変化しないと思うかもしれない。しかしどういうわけか、
qubit 1への操作が実際にqubit 0の2つの部分の間の相対位相を変えることで
qubit 0の状態を変えてしまう。この現象はphase kickback機構として知られており、
多くの量子現象と同様、非常に反直感的だ。ある意味でphase kickback機構は
ボートを漕ぐことに例えられる。水を後ろに押す行為が実際に前に進む推進力になる。まるでqubit 1への操作が
実際にqubit 0を変えるように。ではDeutscheのアルゴリズムを
Qiskitで実行してみよう。ここでブラックボックスに入れる関数を選択できる。今回はF3を選んだ。
アルゴリズムのcircuit図で、sampler primitiveを使って前と同じように実行できる。
サンプル数を1に設定して何が測定されるか見てみよう。この場合、1が測定された。
つまり関数は均衡だとわかる。ブラックボックスに関数f3が含まれていたので、確かにその通りだ。たった1回の
クエリで、この2つのクラスの関数を区別することができた。
古典的なアルゴリズムでは判定に2回のクエリが必要だっただろう。これは量子
コンピューティングが古典コンピューティングよりも控えめながら優位であることを示しているが、それほど印象的ではない。1対2だけだ。しかしDeutscheのアルゴリズムは
量子コンピューティングの歴史において今でも非常に重要だ。他の人々に火をつけ、
より大規模で洗練された量子アルゴリズムについて考えさせるきっかけになったからだ。
その中には、Deutschのアルゴリズムのマルチqubit拡張版が含まれており、はるかに印象的な量子優位性を実証している。
これはDeutsch-Jozaアルゴリズムと呼ばれる。似たような問題を解くが、この場合、ブラックボックス関数は
nビットを入力として受け取り、1ビットを出力する。
前と同様に、関数は定数（出力ビットが常に1か常に0）か、
入力ビット列に関係なく、またはバランス型（出力が
入力ビット列の半分に対して0で、残り半分に対して1）であると約束されている。もちろん、
nビットを1ビットに変換する関数で、定数でもバランス型でもないものは他にも存在する。しかしこの問題では、
そういった関数はブラックボックスの中にないと約束されている。箱の中にあるのは定数かバランス型のどちらかであることが保証されている。
Deutsch-Jozaのcircuitは似ているが、より多くのqubitを使う。ここでは
3ビット関数について学ぶDeutsch-Jozaアルゴリズムの実装がある。今回は3つのqubitがある
入力状態のためで、1つだけでなく。そして最後のqubitが出力状態のためだ。前と同様に、
すべての入力qubitを0＋1の状態に、出力qubitを
0マイナス1の状態に準備する。その後、数学は少し複雑になるが、原理は
同じだ。関数が定数なら、上の3つのqubitには全く依存しない。だからそれらの状態は
2回目のHadamardの後にゼロに戻り、測定は3ビットのすべてゼロの文字列をもたらす。
しかし関数がバランス型なら、Hadamardの後にqubitを測定すると、位相キックバック
機構によってそれらのビットの1つ以上が1になる。今回はそれほど分かりやすくないかもしれないが、自分で
各ステップを解いていけば、すぐにこれが正しいとわかるだろう。これを確認する一つの方法は、
バランス型関数ですべてゼロを測定する確率を計算してみることだ。確率はゼロになるはずだ。
QiskitでDeutsch-Jozaアルゴリズムを量子コンピュータで実行してみよう。最も難しいステップはおそらくDeutsch-Joza
関数を作ることだ。それがここでクエリするブラックボックスになる。このコードはランダムなDeutsch-Joza関数を生成し、
バランス型か定数型のどちらかであることが保証されている。次にDeutsch-JozaのcircuitをつくりブラックボックスをつないでいIく。
また、samplerでcircuitを実行し、測定後に
測定されたビットを見て、関数がバランス型か定数型かを判断する。
すべてゼロなら定数型だ。しかし文字列に少なくとも1つの1ビットがあれば、バランス型だ。この
場合、1、1、1のビット列を得る。
だから、関数がバランス型だったとわかる。量子アルゴリズムがどのように興味深く、しばしば微妙な量子現象を
利用して古典的なアルゴリズムに対する優位性を得るか、その最初の一端を垣間見せられたと思う。
量子アルゴリズムを設計することがいかに難しいかも感じ取れただろう。最初の
アルゴリズムでも、古典的な方法に対してわずかな勝利を収めるのに多くの創意工夫が必要だった。そしてその最初のアルゴリズム以来、
物理学者とコンピュータ科学者たちは量子力学を利用する非常に独創的な方法を考え続けており、
Deutsch-Jozaアルゴリズムのさらなる拡張と応用もその中に含まれる。これらについて
学んだり、DeutschとDeutsch-Jozaアルゴリズムを自分で試したりしたいなら、
説明欄のリンクにあるモジュールにアクセスして始めよう。ご視聴ありがとう、また次回。